[Music]
let's suppose that you were able every
night to dream any dream you wanted to
dream and that you could have the power
within one night to dream 75 years of
time
and you would naturally as you began on
this adventure of Dreams fulfill all
your wishes
but now let's um let's have a surprise
let's have a dream which isn't under
control
[Music]
and then you would get more and more
adventurous
and you would make further and further
out Gamble's as to what you would
breathe
and finally you would dream where you
are now
[Music]
and now he's the head of Xbox please
welcome Bill Spencer
for eighteen years and three generations
we designed Xbox consoles to power your
dreams we see a future where you're
instantly absorbed in your games where
worlds are even more like like immersive
responsive and surprising where you are
at the center of your gaming experience
next holiday Xbox series X will lead us
into the future of console gaming our
fastest most powerful Xbox will set a
new bar for performance speed
compatibility developers around the
globe are already hard at work building
games for Xbox series X our 15 xbox game
studios are developing the largest and
most creatively diverse lineup of
exclusive games in our history tonight
I'm proud to reveal a project early in
development from incredibly talented
creative team who are no strangers to
the game Awards
what you're about to see was all
captured in engine as being built to
take full advantage of Xbox series X
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the sleeve is so
[Music]
all right the fun is just beginning let
me assure you we've got some other great
surprises coming up here at the game
awards now we just ran a poll on twitch
you see who you think is gonna be
recognized as the best eSports player
and there's